and there's a new plan to help school
children catch up over the summer but
education leaders are warning that there
are no
quick fixes to so much disrupted
education well let's get more on this
we're joined now by the education
secretary gavin williamson thank you for
being on the program
can you just talk us through what to
expect from this announcement what
exactly should parents be expecting
well this is a added boost to education
and to children
we recognize that all children have
missed out on so much over the last year
and that's why
uh just six months ago we announced the
one billion pound uh catch up fund
but on top of that we're putting an
extra 700 million pounds into this
this will see extra money 200 million
pounds going to secondary schools to
roll out uh summer lessons and summer
camps if that's what the route they want
to do
par expansion of our national tutoring
program so we can really target
resources to those children who
need it most to give them that extra
boost to help them
catch up on some of the classroom time
that they've missed
but we've got to recognize but you
talked
about the most disadvantaged children
and being targeted
at them but some people are going to be
wondering if this is enough i mean 10
years of progress
between closing the gap between the most
disadvantaged and more privileged peers
has been wiped out according to the
education endowment fund this apparently
works out about six thousand pounds per
primary school is it enough should you
not be looking at more drastic measures
like lending school days or
shortening the school holiday so we're
looking at a whole sort of range of
different actions but what we wanted to
do is to give
schools the extra resources that they
needed to be able to take
action immediately some of the reforms
that we want to
look at and sort of consult on will sort
of
look at the whole expanse of what we can
do in terms of helping
children uh have extra teaching time
have extra opportunities but this is an
immediate response
to give those children that extra boost
but the best support we can do is seeing
children back into the classroom on the
8th of march
which is i think something that all
parents want to see
all children want to see and teachers
want to see as well
so just to pick up that you're saying
you're consulting on a whole range of
things about extending teaching time
does that mean you
are looking at extending the school day
well we recently appointed sir kevin
collins in order to be able to
look at how we do education recovery a
man who's had so many years of
experience
and we're looking at a whole range a
broad range of different options of how
we can support
schools how we can support teachers but
most importantly how we can support
children and that's a whole range
including lengthening the school day
uh well uh he will be looking at how we
can
boost and support children in a whole
range of different
uh manners but it's not just about uh
it's not just about time in school it's
about supporting teachers in terms of
the quality of teaching
and how we can help them okay sounds
like it is on the table though
um i just want to ask about the timing
of this announcement as well this extra
top-up money
um children have experienced right now
330
days of disrupted education since they
were closed in that first lockdown and i
just wonder
if this feeds into you know a wider
theme if you
effectively just doing things too late
at the last minute after they've already
become obvious i mean you announced more
laptops for schools for example
back in april many still don't have them
now you announced the beginning of
january the exams
were going to be cancelled without
announcing a plan of what was going to
replace them i mean are you basically
you know the essay crisis education
secretary you know you only do things
right at the last minute and you leave
other people to pick up the pieces
so what we announced is a billion pound
fund in terms of boosting children's
education giving them extra help and
support and schools that extra help and
support
over six months ago this is the extra
action that we're taking because
actually children have suffered more
disruption as a result of that
we always recognize that the best form
assessment for children
was through exams but when we're in a
situation where we had to
lock down schools again and we weren't
being able to welcome children into
schools
we did have to take another route we've
made it clear
that that's through teacher judgment and
teacher assessment as to how those
grades will be awarded
and our focus is very much in terms of
welcoming children
back on the 8th of march it's an
incredibly important part of our
unlocking of the country but it also
goes to confirm for priority that the
prime minister and i have always said
the national priority
is our children and their education uh
we've always said
schools would be the last to close and
first to open and we've been absolutely
true to our word
so what is your plan then to replace
exams you say that you recognize it's
the best form of teacher
assessment how are you going to replace
them well what we already set out
um in sort of the first week of january
is the fact that we'd be
putting teacher judgment at the core of
it it would be teacher assessed
grades uh that would be what
is the basis of gcse's and a levels
uh we're in the next few days going to
be outlining the details
uh further details of the plan following
the consultation that we carried out
with the sector
that had one of the largest responses
that uh of any consultation that we've
ever run
i understand you know you need to
consult you need to get this right
because it's so important but what i
don't understand is when exams were
cancelled last year when it was entirely
predictable that they could be cancelled
again this year
why didn't you announce a comprehensive
plan at the same time
as announcing that they were going to be
cancelled it would really help
parents and children as well and the
anxiety levels
well as you probably recall back in
january we did set out very clearly that
we're moving to
uh teacher judgement in terms of
assessment and grades
and we absolutely rightly wanted to
consult on this we'll be setting out for
details
incredibly shortly in the next few days
and you'll have to sort of uh
just wait a short time longer before we
set out more details
on that but the best form of assessments
has always been examination
that's why we had felt the best route as
many of the countries right around for
the world
even where they've been dealing with the
pandemic could also reach that same
conclusion
but in terms of a changing situation
we felt it's right to be able to consult
on a different route
and sort of set out our contingency
plans in terms of doing that that's what
we did
we completed the consultation and we'll
be informing
both children teachers and parents have
resulted that incredibly soon
contingency plan does that mean people
could still have sick exams then
no no okay i'm interested to hear about
universities
as well they're not included they
weren't included in the roadmap this
week can you guarantee
to university students that they're
going to get some face-to-face teaching
by the end of this academic year well i
do apologize to correct you but
um they were actually included as part
of a road map and actually what you're
seeing is
from the 8th of from the 8th of march
you'll be seeing all practical students
being able to return that's roughly
about
40 percent of all students studying at
university so
a very significant increase in the
number of students that are going to be
going back to university
i equally recognize that there's many
more students that
are not covered in that that's why as
part of the next stage there is a
review about when we can bring chil
students back into university as the
earliest possible moment
um this is uh the right time to do so
um i certainly want to be seeing uh
students back into the
university at the earliest possible
moment that's why we're conducting a
review
and that's why we're going to be
welcoming so many back on the 8th of
march
as you say the majority of students um
we're still not clear when they're going
to return can you guarantee that all
university students will have some
face-to-face teaching this academic year
yeah we want to be seeing all students
whatever courses
they're doing to be having face-to-face
teaching this year that's why we're
setting up the review point of the
next stage of a roadmap as to when we're
going to be able to make
absolutely clear that all students are
going to be able to return back to
university
okay now james wharton the former
concept of mp someone you know very well
obviously because she both worked
together
on boris johnson's leadership campaign
he's been appointed the head
of the independent regulator for higher
education
in england can you just talk me through
what experience he's got in that sector
because i mean
oh i've had a look i can't really find
any well james brings an immense amount
of experience both as a government
minister
as a lawyer before entering uh
parliament
but also as a chairman of
a business and bringing business
experience as well as public service
experience into that role
and what he will be is an incredibly
strong voice and champion
uh for students as well as the sector
making sure that we drive up standards
in the sector making sure that we
uh drive up the quality of what
students get from universities and
helping
you know the sector deliver real change
in terms of what they deliver in terms
of
student experience and i think we need
to have strong advocates
in organizations such as the office for
students
there's a absolutely rightly there to
hold universities to account and i have
no doubt
that he will do exactly that as he did
in his ministerial career
well i'm glad that you've got no doubt
because other people have got some
doubts
on this and you know he's been given
this very
lucrative role 60 000 pound a year for
two days a week
in the university sector when i asked
what relevant
experience in that sector you've got you
said he's been a minister and a lawyer i
mean you can understand why some people
might think hang on a minute
is this just jobs for the boys well
actually
so many of these incredibly important
public appointments is making sure that
you have strong advocates for the sector
making sure that you have strong strong
voices for students that
is what uh lord wharton will be and i
have no doubt that he will take
the enthusiasm and the passion that he
always had whether as a
differed minister whether as a minister
for the northern powerhouse
into that exact same role in terms of
advocating for universities
and advocating for students making sure
that we drive a quality agenda
in terms of making sure that teaching
within universities continues to improve
these are all things that are absolutely
vital that the office for students does
and this follows an extensive
independent uh
sort of recruitment process and one
where he was also
interviewed by the select committee in
parliament which also endorsed his
import
appointment as well very quickly because
we are at a time
um but this comes off the back of other
people who are known to the
this government being awarded lucrative
contracts and for example neighbor of
matt hancock getting 30 million pounds
to produce violence for covert tests
are we really meant to believe that this
is all just complete coincidence that
they have relationships with
members of government and they were
really appointed because they were the
best people for the job
we always appoint for people who are
best person for the job driving the
government's agenda in terms of change
and reform whether that's in
universities whether that's in schools
whether that's in any other sector of
society because actually we want to
deliver change we want to deliver the
leveling up agenda
that's always the focus and our focus is
getting the best people
into those jobs to deliver that change
and help us deliver the agenda
that we were elected to deliver back in
2019